Northern California's devastating
wildfires are now the deadliest in the
state's history they have killed at
least 31 people 400 others are
reportedly missing in Sonoma County
alone
the officials believe many are just out
of touch with their families at least
25,000 people in the region have
evacuated 21 major wildfires are burning
statewide this morning the last home of
peanuts creator Charles Schulz was one
of the buildings lost in Santa Rosa
Carter Evans is in Santa Rosa where some
people are seeing the damage for the
first time Carter good morning good
morning authorities are now
investigating to determine if down
powerlines may be the cause of the fire
that burned so many homes like this one
in Santa Rosa this is what thousands of
people had to come home to charred
debris that stretches for miles what's
over here back on this end this is
different porch right here this is the
deck that redwood deck right here and
that's the front door Tom fell bomb left
his house Monday with just a clothes on
his back he and his wife Sue lived here
for 28 years
what does it like to come back here and
see all of your stuff like this get your
stuff the hard thing is the photo albums
and they like the movies that's the hard
thing in so many neighborhoods like the
fell bombs
it's an apocalyptic sight this mail
truck continued its deliveries to the
mailboxes still standing along the
blackened backdrop authorities are now
moving on to the recovery phase
searching for victims within the rubble
identifications going to be hard so far
in the recoveries we have found bodies
that were almost completely intact and
we have found bodies that were nothing
more than ash and bones
elsewhere the fight to preserve what's
left is far from over
let's go cruising calistoga are battling
not just the weather but the terrain as
the fire creeps up steep hillsides
they're everywhere
you know there's little pockets there's
parts that we just can't get to you know
he just saved some houses down the
street and it was there's no better
feeling though you know Jason Stevens
has been living in this parking lot
since his apartment burned to the ground
all of his other possessions are gone
those things can be replaced but there's
a lot of things they can't that people
have lost I consider myself fortunate as
bad as this is it could have been so
much worse
it could have been so much worse one of
the most astounding things about this
fire is how indiscriminantly it burned
I'm gonna stay in basically the same
spot here and just rotate around you can
see the homes just across the street are
in perfect condition be honest
unbelievable Carter and the fire chief
said it's going to get worse before it
gets better thank you so much